[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
محاكمه حوثيه لثلاثه نشاطئ على يوتيوب
بتهمه اذاعه اخبار كاذبه والتحريض على
الفوضى
تعزيز التحالف الدولي للتصدي لاي تهديدات
صينيه عبر الفضاء
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من تطورات
الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث اعلن الجيش
الاوكراني في بيان ان القوات الروسيه
تكبدت خسائر كبيره في معارك السوليدار
وقالت فرقه القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه ان
اكثر من 100 جندي روسي
اكيد الصحيفه يد جورنال تكبد القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه خسائر فادحه في
المعالي قربهم حيث نقلت عن احد اقاله
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه الموجوده قرب
بخمد ان الخسائر الاوكرانيه تفوق خسائر
الروس ورجح القائد الاوكراني امكانيه
التراجع في حال استمرار الوضع على حال هذا
هذا ولفته الصحيفه الى تفضيل
وغربيين مغادره القوات الاخراني
جديد وذلك على خلفيه الخسائر التي تكبرت
الاخيره هذا هو اظهر مقطع فيديو مصور
انتشر على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي جنود
اخرى هنيه
السيطره عليها فيما الدفاع الروسيه تقول
ان المعارك ما زالت مستمره
طيب
كشف الصور الفضائي
الامريكي
بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه حول بلدتي
المتجاورتين على خط المواجهه شرقيه
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
حضرت صوره
العسكريه الروسيه في سوريا
[موسيقى]
في احدث تغيير بالقياده العسكريه لروسيا
في اوكرانيا قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
هيئه الاركان العامه
للقوات فيما تسبيه العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا واكدت وزاره الدفاع في
بيان ان التعديل يهدف الى تحسين الاتصالات
بين مختلف افرع الجيش ورفع جوده وفاعليه
هيكل للقياده واداره العمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا
فاليري كريسموف رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه
الروسيه يصبح القائد الجديد للعمليه
العسكريه باوكرانيا ولد في مدينه قازان
عام
1955 تخرج من مدرسه قزان العليا للدبابات
درس في الاكاديميه العسكريه للقوات
المدرعه وتخرج منها عام
والاكاديميه العسكريه للهيئه الاركان
العامه للقوات المسلحه الروسيه عام 1997
عينا بمناصب عسكريه عده ابرزها رئيس اركان
منطقه شمال القوقاز العسكريه
ورئيس اركان منطقه الشرق الاقصى العسكريه
نائب رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه عام 2010
رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه الروسيه منذ عام
2012 حتى الحادي عشر من يناير عام 2023
هذا ولا تزرع العمليات العسكريه الروسيه
والقذف الجوي والمدفعي مستمرين في منطقه
دونياسك شرق اوكرانيا
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا قبل احد عشر
شهرا لعل اكثر 10 حراسه سجلتها المناطق
الواقعه شرقي البلاد حيث المعارك مشتعله
في دونجاس تفاصيل اكثر مع الزميله ليال
الاختيار
قبل اقل من عام بدات روسيا عمليتها
العسكريه بدخول اقليم جمباز من الشرق فما
هي ابرز محطات العمليه الروسيه شرقي
اوكرانيا القوات الروسيه وصلت التقدم في
مارس واقتربت من السيطره على اول مدينه
اوكرانيه كبيره شمال شرقي البلاد وهي كمان
نشاهد هنا حركات انتصار وصف بالاستراتيجيه
تحقق في شهر مايو بالسيطره على ماريوبل
المطله على بحر از اوف بعد صمود نحو جندي
اوكرانيه داخل مصنع اثاث ستايل للصلب
لحوالي الشهر بعد السيطره الروسيه على
ماريو بيل ومدن عده في اقليم جمباز بقيت
على الجانب الاخر في الشرق مدينه
حينها في الثامن والعشرين من مايو تمكنت
القوات المواليه لروسيا من السيطره على
مدينه ليمان مركز مهم السكك الحديديه في
منطقه دونياس كما هو معروف في يونيو
الماضي اعلن حاكم لو جانسك سيطرت القوات
الروسيه على مدينه سيفرودونياسك
الاستراتيجيه في الثالث من يوليو وبعد
احكام السيطره على دنيا
اعلنت القوات الروسيه السيطره على منطقه
لوجاست فيما تبقى امامها منطقه دونياس
لاحكام قبضتها على اقليم دومباز باكمله
انذاك كما نذكر شهر سبتمبر شهد مشاهدينا
تقدما اوكرانيا شرقي مع السعاده بلدات
رئيسيه بينها ايسيوم في ديسمبر وبدايه
العام الجديد تتركز الجهود الروسيه على
مدينتي سفرياس وباخمه المجاورتين
وصولي دار المجاوره هي الطريقه الاقرب
لتحقيق هذه الاهداف
من مصر مشاهدينا تنضم الينا مراسه العربيه
كات يطيع ما اهلا بكاتها تعيين كاس موف في
هذا التوقيت قائد للقوات الروسيه كيف كانت
اصداو في داخل الروسي
مرحبا صباح الخير كان طبعا تغييرات التي
حدثت يوم امس والتي اعلن عنها وزير الدفاع
الروسيه
حقيقه مفاجاه لشارع الروسي لان كنا قد
لاحظنا وفقا لم تناقته وسائل الاعلام ايضا
كان هناك تغييرات ايضا في همم
تعيين الجنرال لافين قائد
المنشات بالاضافه الى ذلك همم
تراسل العمليات العمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا لم يتم تعيينه الا من فتره قريره
فهذه التغيرات التي حدثت يوم امس وكما
مررتها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها فقط
لرفع مستوى العمليات في همم على الارض في
اوكرانيا كانت هي الحقيقه مفاجاه لشارع
الروسي يوم امس
لكن
الاوساط العسكريه وهل يعور عليه كثيرا في
تج وبالاخطاء التي صاحبت الاداء الروسيه
والعمليه العسكريه الروسيه في الفتره
الماضيه
كما ذكر
ت التي قالت بشكل رسمي انها همم تقوم بهذه
التغييرات فقط لرفع مستوى اا العمليات على
الارض وطبعا هذه التغييرات هي ايضا تاتي
بعد الضربه التي طلقتها روسيا ليله راس
السنه بعد مقتل همم الجنود في همم بقصرها
من الجانب الاوكراني كان قد قتل نحوها 65
جندي روسي يمكن
من اجل ان يكون هناك وقايه اكبر واحتياط
اكبر لحمايه القوات الروسيه عن الارض وان
لا يكون هناك اخطاء او تكرر مثل هذه
الاخطاء التي طبعا همم وقعت عند راس السنه
وضربه التي وجهت الى روسيا طبعا هذا
التغيرات ايضا تاتي هي بتوازي مع اتقدم
والمعارك التي نشهدها في سردار هناك كان
طبعا هناك كان همم عدم وضوح في حال اذا
كان تم السيطره على هذه المدينه او لا
هناك كانت تصريحات متناقضه الدفاع فعلا
تؤكد فيما اذا تمت همم على هذه المدينه هي
قالت فقط انها همم محاصره من الشمال ومن
الجنوب بينما كانت قوات باتنه قد تحدثت
انها وصلت الى مركز المدينه وان هذه تقوم
بعمليه تطهير هناك وان هي القوات الوحيده
على الارض هناك والتي قامت بسيطره على هذه
مدينه سوليدار والتي هي على الرغم من
صغرها صغرها احمد ولكنها اهميه استراتيجيه
لانها تشكل المفتاح للسيطره فيما بعد على
مدينه باخوات الاوكرانيه كثيره
[موسيقى]
في الداخل راني مشاهدينا ارسلت الناشطه
سبيدا جاليان من داخل سجن ايفين بطيران
رساله الى الراي العام خلال قناه ايران
ناشونال وقالت الفتاه الايرانيه ان عمليه
الاعترافات القصريه للسجناء مستمره واصفه
ما يحدث في البلاد بانه صوت الثوره وفي
رسالتها قالت سبيدا انه بالرغم من تماسكها
داخل السجن الا انها تشعر بالخوف من حملات
التعذيب والاعدام والقمع وظيفه ال المبنى
الثقافيه في سجن ايفن تحول الى مكان
للتعذيب وانتزاع الاعترافات كما اكلت
الفتاه الايرانيه انها اجبرت على اعتراف
قصريا امام احدى الكاميرات بعد تعذيب
استمر ثلاثه ايام ما ادى الى فقدانها
الوعي هذا هو ادانا رئيس لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ الامريكي حكم محكمه
ايرانيه على الصحفيه الايرانيه في درباني
بالسجن سبع سنوات وثلاثه اشهر بتهمه
التجمع والتواطئ ضد الامن القومي الى جانب
اطلاق الدعايه ضد النظام وكانت مجموعه
حقوقيه طالب بالافراج عنها وعن جميع الصح
او المحتاجين الذين اواجهوا حمله اعتقالات
واسعه على اثر احتجاجات المتواصله في
البلاد
مشاهدينا قالت ايضا منظمه العفو الدوليه
ان على السلطات الايرانيه ان توقف فورا
جميع عمليات الاعدام المتعلقه بالاحتجاجات
التي تشهدها البلاد واداره المنظمه في
بيان ما وصفته بالاعدام التعسفي لكل من
محمد مهدي كرامي وسيد محمد حسيني محاضره
بانه هناك اخرين يواجهون نفس المصير ودانه
المنظمه استماره السلطات الايرانيه في
موجه القتل وسعيها المستميت لنهايه
الاحتجاجات من خلال اشاعه الخوف بين الناس
متهمه السلطات الاداريه باستخدام الاعدام
كسلاح للقامه
من بركه المشاهدين تنضمون الباحث في جهه
الايرانيه منى السيلاوي اهلا بك سيد منى
النظام الايراني دائما معين في الاتهامات
بارتكابه تجاوزات في حق النساء في السجون
وارتداء عليهم هل تحملوا هذه الاتهامات
قدرا من المبالغه ام ان ذلك هو الواقع
فعلا في السجون الايرانيه
ما تحصل في ايران هي لديها اكثر من كتاب
ذكرت فيها عن تعذيب عن النساء لم يكن
لهاتهن اصوات مثلا نحن مع الاسف من عرب
الاهوازيات لدينا كان كثير من السجينات
ولكن بسبب الطبيعه الذكوريه للمجتمع
وتقليديه المجتمع كانوا اهالي يتكتمون
قضيه همم تلك السجينات فهي كانت على رقم
انها ليست عربيه ولكن تعاطفت مع تلك
النسوه ليست ليست لديهم حتى يتحدثنا يعني
عربيات ولا يعرفنا الفارسيه ومعتقلات
سجينات سياسيه فهي كتب الكتاب عن معاناتهن
يعني كيف فعل ليست اول مره تقوم بهذه
اعمال سيد الشجاعه جدا همم
في العاده ما تقولها حقيقه ومن يخرج ايضا
همم اذا يؤكد ما قالته استفيد ولذلك على
رقم انه اتهامها وهي بالسجن تغطيه
ديت اخبار حركات والاحتجاجات والعماليه
حتى الان نراها من سجن ومن تبعيد لتبعيد
من المدينه الى المدينه ويرضون اداء اطلاق
حريتها طيب استدمونا يعني الملاحظه انا
دائما المراه هي كلمه السر في جميع
الانتهاكات التي يتهم النظام ارتكابه هذا
مواطنين لماذا استهداف المراه تحديدا
[موسيقى]
عندما تخرج يحاولون اسكاتها كما يحاولون
اذا مثلا لما النظام يهدد انه يقومون
باغتصاب النساء وتعذيب النساء يريدون ايضا
جرح الذكريات هذه المجتمع حتى يمنعون
المراه ان تشارك حتى الرجال مثلا هذه
المراه مثلا يمنعونها ان تخرج وتطالب
بحقوق ذلك النظام الايراني
لديها كثير من السجينات في سجون احيانا
الاهل يتعاطفون مع بنتهم وخلف بنتهم
قطريات مساء
بالفعل موقف البطولي للاهل لانه وقفوا خلف
ولكن الغالبيه العظمى مع الاسف يعني حتى
هذا الطبيعي التقليديه لذلك النظام يضع
يده هناك يعني حتى يمنع حتى يتركها او
يجبر الرجال في العائله يمنعون النساء
شاركنا فيه حياه السياسيه او في الاحتجاج
شكرا
الايراني من السيلاوي تحياتي
اصدرت ايران مشاهدينا حكما باعدام علي رضا
اكبر وهو مسؤول سابق عامر مستشاره وزير
الدفاع الايراني السابق ويحمل جنسيه
مزدوجه ايرانيه بريطانيه بتهمه التجسس
البريطانيا وقالت وزاره الاستخبارات
الايرانيه ان اكبر احد احد اهم المخترقين
للمراكز الحساسه والاستراتيجيه في البلاد
كما كشف موقع
للقضاء الايراني انه تم الحكم على اكبر
بالاعدام بتهمه افساد في الارض والمس ايضا
بالامن الداخليه والخارجي معلومات
اطلاقا بحياه البشر على حد وصفهم
كيفك
انني اجتمعت بامين المجلس الاعلى للامن
القومي في عهد الرئيس حسن رحاني
واهديته زجاجه عطر مقابل معلومات سريه عن
الدوله
وانني اعطيتها للاجانب وبمعرفه وزاره
الاطلاعات
قررت بلديه فرنسيه اخفاء صوره للخميني
مؤسس النظام الايراني الحالي واعلن عمده
بلدته نوفل
الفرنسيه ان الصوره الموضوع في ارض خاصه
حيث اقام الخميني اواخر السبعينيات سيتم
اخفائها عن الانظار تماما وجاء هذا القرار
استجابه لطلب من الاتحاد الدولي لحقوق
المراه تقدم به نيابه عن مجموعه من 40
منظمه غير حكوميه وذلك في ظل الاحتجاجات
التي تشهدها ايران
مشاهدينا نشاطنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
العثور على مجموعه جديده من الوثائق
السريه لرئيس بايدين في مكتب اخر
تركزين معروف عنه انه كان متحمسا جدا
للتدخل عسكريا في سوريا لاحقا
[موسيقى]
ولكن هناك اتهامات شخصيه فيها تحقيقات
قضائيه في داخل الفرنسي ضد كوزيت بتلقي
اموال ما كان موقفه في شخصيه من ذلك
لا مو كويسه
الجزء الثاني الجمعه العاشره والنصف على
شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
للاخبار والقصص التي تهمك كل ما هو شائع
ومنتشر عربيا وعالميا في زمن الاحداث
والتغيرات المفاجئه التي يشهدها العالم
العربيه دوت نت بشكله العصري يسمح بتصفح
بلون مختلفين خدمه البث المباشر وعرض
القصص والبرامج حسب الطلب
تذكير بما قد فاتك من اخبار مع تسليط
الضوء على الاخبار التي تحدث بالقرب منك
ابدا الان لتكن على تواصل مع كل ما هو
جديد مصدرك الاول للمعلومات العربيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في جديد
الوثائق السريه التي عثر عليها بمكتب
الرئيس الامريكي حينما كان نائبا لرئيس
اوباما افاد الشبكه ام بي سي نيوز عن مصدر
دون ذكر اسمه بان معاويه رئيس الامريكي
اكتشفوا مجموعه اخرى من الوثائق السريه في
موقع غير مكتبيه السابق عندما كان يشغل
منصب نائب الرئيس
يبحثون عن مواد سريه قد تكون في مواقع
اخرى واكتشفها نحو 12 من السجلات السريه
فيما قال رئيس الامريكي
يتعاونون بشكل كامل مع التحقيق في الامر
قالت اداره الطيران السودانيه امريكيه
انها تواصل مراجعه شامله لتحديد السبب
الجدري لانقطاع نظام الاشعار بالبعثات
الجويه
الاوليه
التي ادت الى حركه الطيران الامريكيه
ظهر وجود ملف في قاعده بيانات تالف مضيفا
بل مضيفه عدم وجود دليل على وقوع هجوم
الكترونيه كما اكدت الهيئه انها تعمل بجهد
لزياده تحديد اسباب هذه المشكله واتخاذ
جميع الخطوات اللازمه لمنع حدوث هذا النوع
من الاضطراب مجددا
بدات ميليشيات الحوثي محاكمه ثلاثه من
اشهر المؤثرين في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
في صنعاء الخاضعه لسيطرتها وذلك بعد
اتهامهم بنشر اخبار كاذبه وتحريض الناس
على الفوضى بحسب وثائق الطلعه عليها وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه المشاهير الثلاثه الذين
تحاكمهم منشيئه الحوثي هم احمد حجر ومصطفى
المومري واحمد علاوي اذا يعد المومري من
المؤثرين في منصه يوتيوب ويتابعه اكثر من
مليون شخص اما احمد عله فهو معلق رياضي
ولديه اكثر من 800,000 متابعين على قناته
في يوتيوب فيما يتابع احمد حجر نحو مئتين
250,000 شخص على قناه في يوتيوب ايضا
وبالعوده الى تفاصيل اتهامات التي وجهتها
لهم من شانه الحوثي فانه وفقا لوفيقه
الادعاء جرتها مهم باذاعه اخبار واشاعات
كاذبه بقصد تكبير الامن العام والحاق
الضرير بالمصلحه العامه اضافه الى اتهامهم
بالتحريض على الفوضى والخروج الى الشوارع
واقتحام الوزارات في مواجهه بل وجهت الى
شخص رابع تهم تقديم المساعده لاحد
النشاطاء
وتنسيق محتويات الفيديوهات
اكثر من مليونين مره
هذا المق
وله الناس كلهم اليمنيين كلهم عن ماسرتوا
ان ماجد يقولوا
انصار
من القاهره مشاهدينا نظام الينا المتحدث
الرسمي باسم وزاره حقوق الانسان اليمنيه
وليد الانباره اهلا بك استاذ وليد معانا
في هذه النشره محاكمه الحوثيين لهؤلاء
المؤثرين من اي زاويه يمكن النظر اليها
صباح الخير لكل الساده المشاهدين اولا
ما تقوم به المليشيات هي اييي محاوله هي
جزء من استراتيجيه هل تكميم الافواه
والسيطره على الفضاء العام بشكل كلي وهو
يندرج ضمن مساعها السابقه التي قامت من
خلالها باغلاق كافه القنوات الرسميه
الحزبيه وكذلك الصحف والاذاعات لم يتبقى
الان في صنعاء اي
وسيله اعلاميه سواء كانت مقروءه ومسموعه
ومرئيه
مستقله او تابعه لجهه معارضه كل هناك صوت
واحد فقط طائفه في صنعاء يتبعه هذه
الميليشيات همم في الفتره الاخيره شاهدنا
كيف ان الناس لجؤوا الى التعبير عن همم ما
يشعرون به وما يعانون به في المناطق التي
تظهر عليها المليشيات الارهابيه عبر
صفحاتهم او مواقعهم او قنواتهم في
اليوتيوب وغيرها همم وبالتالي شاهدنا خلال
الايام الماضيه ان هناك همم بالفعل تاثير
كبير جدا همم
تلقفه الشارع وكان هناك دعوات للظاهرات
وهناك احتقان شعبي لم يعد يخفى على احد
بسبب سلوك هذه الميليشيات وبالتالي
الميليشيات تحاول من خلال هذه الرساله
واحد هي ايقاف الشكوى والانين الذي يقوم
به المواطنين هي لا تريد ان تسمع شكوى
والعنين همم
الحوثيين باستغلال اصوات المناوي لكن لهذه
النقطه التي اشرت اليها الان هل يمكن لهذه
الممارسات ان تسكت فعلا هؤلاء او هذه
الاصوات المعارضه بالعكس هي ستزيد من
عزيمه اصحابها
في الغالب في الغالب نشاهد بان الممارسات
القمعيه والقسريه تنتج اثار عكسيه على
المدى البعيد ولكن احيانا قد تجدي نفعا او
يكون لها تاثير الى حد ما في القمع وخصوصا
ان هذه مليشيات ارهابيه نحن نتحدث عن
مليشيات نظام وحشي وبربري بكل ما تعني هذه
الكلمه بمعنى هي تقول له مجرد القتل
وتحاكم المجلد المحاكمه وبالتالي مثل هذه
الرسائل في البدء يمكن لها بالفعل ان ان
ان تشكل ضغط كبير جدا على النشاطات وعلى
الناس الذين يستعملون الحصول على
مستحقاتهم وعلى حقوقهم المكتسبه بما في
ذلك الرواتب الى اخره ولكن على المدى
البعيد لا شك بان هذه الممارسات الوحشيه
لن تفني شعبنا عن استعاده حقوقه ماذا عن
حقوقهم متهمين نتحدثون عن توكيل محامين عن
استئناف الاحكام الصادر ضدهم هل يصبح لهم
بذلك ام ان هذه المحاكمات كما يقال تفتقد
بادنى مقومات العداله
في الحقيقه
مع احترامنا للجهاز القضاء بشكل عام سواء
الموجود في في المناطق الحكومه الشرعيه
وفي المناطق الحوثيين الا انه بالفعل هذا
القضاء ما تبقى من الجهاز القضائي الموجود
في صنعاء تم السيطره عليه بشكل او باخر
شاهدنا خلال سنوات المرضى الماضيه حدث له
تجريف كبير جدا شاهدنا كيف تعرض على
العديد من الخضار الاختيار للتعذيب
الاختطاف
للمس بالكرامه
وتم الزنجب بالعشرات من الحوثيين الى داخل
القضاء وبالتالي ارسال القضاء همم لا نقول
بان كل القضايا المتواجدين في صنعاء
حوثيين ولكن ايضا صار القضاء تحت الضغط
الحوثيين وبالتالي لا يمكن لجهاز بمفرده
ان يستطيع ان يواجه كل هذا الكم من التبول
همم وبالتالي المحاكمه تفتقر لابسط
الاجراءات القانونيه وهي غير شرعيه بكل
مثلا
هذه المحاكمات ليست شرعيه فلها اي صفات
السوريه او قانونيه هي فقط محاوله اخراج
ل- اا نوع ما
نسميها التقنين في عمليات تحت الكسر اا
اعتذر بك هذا ما سمع به الوقت شكرا لك من
القاهره كنت مع المتحدث الرسمي باسمي
وزاره حقوق الانسان اليمنيه وليد العباره
تحياتي
[موسيقى]
برر نائب المتحدث باسم حركه طالبان بلال
كريمي قرار الاماره في افغانستان منع
تعليم المراه في الجامعه بان الحركه من
واجبها تنظيم وشؤون التعليم والتنميه في
البلاد وفقا لاحكام الشريعه وفي مقابله
خاصه مع العربيه قال ان النظام طالبان منح
المراه حقوقه لم تكن موجوده في السابق
خير يوقف نظره
الاسلاميه تتكون من علماء وطلاب يهتمون
بالعلوم والتربيه والتعليم اكثر من اي فئه
اخرى والاماره لا تعارض تعليم اي شخص باي
شكل من الاشكال ولكنها مسؤوله عن تنظيم
المراحل التربويه والتعليميه وكل ما يتعلق
بذلك فهي مسؤوله وترى ان من واجبها ان
يكون ذلك وفقا لاحكام الشريعه الاسلاميه
والمبادئ الاسلاميه
كما قلنا نائب المتحدث باسم حركه طالبان
بلال كريم اهميه وجود تنظيم داعش في
افغانستان ووصفه بالظاهره التكفيريه غير
المرئيه واكد ان الاماره قضت على ثمانيه
وتسعين في المئه من اوقات التنظيم مشيرا
الى عدم وجود حاضنه شعبيه له في افغانستان
ان ظاهره داعش تكفيريه ليس لها وجود مادي
ومرئي وملموس في بلادنا فبعد مجيء اماره
الاسلاميه تم القضاء على
98% من عناصر التنظيم وتم تدميره ولكن من
المؤسف ان بعض الدوائر تدعمه من خلال
الاعلام او تموله الاستغلاله ولكن في
الممارسه العمليه ما نراه في الواقع
الميداني لبلدنا هذه الظاهره لا تشكل
تحديا كبيرا وليست مصدرا قلق جاد للامن
الداخلي في بلادنا ولا يمكنه ان يشكل
تهديدا من افغانستان الى دول اخرى
ماذا يشرب قدر تشيزي قال النبي
داعش امرا مهما لكي نحتاج الى دول اخرى
لمواجهته داعش ليس تنظيما قويا وليس مهما
ليتمكن من تجنيد الاشخاص عندنا وليس له
مناطق ثابته فحيث نجد نشاطا تخريبيا
منفردا تطارده قوات الدوله ومخابره
الاماره الاسلاميه ويتم تدمير او تاره
[موسيقى]
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل بدء
المرحله الرابعه من عمليه فصل التوام
السيامي العراقيه عمر وعلي في الرياض
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا افاده مراسل العربيه
بان توام السيامي العراقيه عمر وعلي دخلا
قبل قليل او بدات المرحله الرابعه اذا من
عمليه فصل
التوامين في مستشفى الملك عبد الله
التخصصي للاطفال بالعاصمه السعوديه الرياض
وكانت توام العراقي قديم الى السعوديه في
سبتمبر الماضي بعد توجيهات خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بدراسه بدراسه حاله
التوام والنظر في امكانيه اجراء عمليه
لفصلهما عن بعضهم البعض
للشعب السعودي وللحكومه السعوديه والدكتور
عبد الله الربيع بشكل خاص وباقي الفريق
وباقي الفريق الطبي العام على فصل التوام
السياميه هذه مو اول عملي حيث يقوم بها
بالسعوديه عراقيه
بنجاح ان شاء الله ويرجعون الى بلدهم
وشكرا الى القلب بارك الله فيكم هو اكد
دكتور عبد الله ربيعه المشرفه على عمليه
فصل التوام السيامي العراقي عمر وعلي اكد
ان الفحوصات الاوليه تظهر حاله من
الاستقرار بعد نهايته مرحله التعقيب
الاولى
نحن الان نتمنى المرحله الاولى وبدايه
المرحله الثانيه وهي مرحله التعقيم التوام
الان وضعهم ولله الحمد مستقر كل المؤشرات
الحيويه ولله الحمد جيده تم تركيب اجهزه
التخدير انابيب التخدير انابيب القاصرات
الوليديه قساطر الرقابه الحيويه فا الوضع
ولله الحمد مطمن بعد مرحله التعقيم التي
لن تاخذ طويلا سوف تبدا فتح الجراح لتوام
والدخول في منطقه اسفل الصدر والبطن
والتاكد بشكل اكيد من الاشتراكات التي
اظهرت الفحوصات ان التوام مشتركين او
مشتركان في همم الكبد والقنوات الصفراويه
او المراريه
مين مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصيه
لاطفال في الرياض يضب الينا مراسل العربيه
هاني الصفيان اهلا بك هاني وكيف تسير
المرحله الرابعه من هذه العمليه
سوف تستغرق قرابه الساعه ونصف الساعه
الطاقه الطبيه انا موجود بالكامل في داخل
الغرفه طبعا الان نشاهد الصوره
تماما الدكتور عبد الله الربيعه وكذلك
الدكتور عبد الله مشان رئيس قسم جراحه همم
الاطفال وكذلك الطاقه ايضا بحضور
البروفيسور اسامه المشهداني الذي قدم من
العراق يوم امس والذي ايضا يتابع الان مع
الطاقه الطبيه السعوديه حاله فصل التوام
السيامي ولكن ايضا سوف ناخذ هذه التفاصيل
بشكل كامل مع الدكتور نزار
الزغبي وهو ايضا رئيس قسم التقدير الاطفال
في مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي مرحبا
بك يا دكتور دكتور
نزار يعني تمت المرحله الاولى وكنت تشرف
عليها وهي مرحله التخدير وهي من المراحل
المهمه ايضا والان بالمرحله الرابعه ادينا
نتحدث عن هالمرحله هذه المهمتين بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم شكرا لكم بالنسبه لمرحله
التخدير تمت في اادام الساعه السابعه و 55
دقيقه بدخول التوامين لغرف العمليات وتم
تخدير كل طفل على حدى البدايه ثم وضع
الانابيب يتنفس والقاصرات الحيويه وقاصات
الشريانيه
ولله الحمد تمت المرحله في ساعه ونصف قبل
الوقت المحدد اللي هو مخصص لها ساعتين
وتمت بثلاثه ومؤشرات الحيويه للطفلين
الحمد لله مستقره همم طبعا همم نوهن عمليه
التخدير مستمره لنهايه العمليه هي بس
مراحل الاولى هي بدايه همم
الان احنا في المرحله الرابعه يعني مرحله
فصل الامعاء والكبد وهمم وتم وضع الصبغه
اثناء عمليه
المراريه وعصاره همم الصفراويه الحمد لله
فانتقل اليك السؤال ولكن دعنا نشاهد ايضا
ويكون معي مشاهدين قناه العربيه للمرحله
الرابعه التي تتم الان كما تذكرت ان
الدكتور عبدالله الربيع وايضا الدكتور عبد
الله النمشان والطاقه الطبي الان يقوم
يقومون بفصل او عمليه الفصل وهي من
المراحل الحساسه خاصه ان تتم عمليه الفصل
كما تحدث الدكتور نزار وكذلك قبل ذلك
الدكتور عبد الله والدكتور محمد المنشاوي
عن ان تتم عمليه الفاصل من همم مرحله
الكبد وهي فصلت الكبد وكذلك ايضا سوف
تنتقل وتستمر خلال ساعه ونصف ساعه سوف
انتقل اليك دكتور نزار ايضا في سؤال اخر
بعد هذه العمليه ما الذي سوف يج من مراحل
اخرى المرحله
فيها الان هي فصل الكبد والامعاء وبعدين
فصل التوام هذه المرحله الرابعه
تتم في هذه المرحله
الكبد بعدين فصح الجزار الخلفي لا ما في
عظام الجزء الخلفي
بعدين يضع وضع
كل طفل على حدا وتبدا عمليه الترميم
والاربعاء الفصل الثاني
همم اعاده الترميم الامعاء
والكبد وهمم
الحلقه الاخيره
المرحله الخطيره المهمه يعني
هي اكثر
شكرا لك يا دكتور نزال اذا طاقم الطبي في
مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي بوزاره
الحرس الوطني همم نستطيع ان نقول انه يقوم
الان باجراء اصعب واخطر مرحله من المراحل
الست لفصل التوام السيامي عمر وعلي وهي
مرحله عمليه فصل الكبد وكذلك فصل الجدار
ليتم وضع كل طفل على حده وتتم الان
وتستغرق ساعه ونصف ساعه تقريبا وبعد ذلك
يتم عمليه تجميل وعمليه ايضا تضميد باقي
الاجزاء الاعضاء وهي ان نشاهدها الان ولو
يقترب قليلا همم المصور ونرى العمليه
الدقيقه التي يقوم بها الفريق الطبي الان
في مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي وكذلك
بجانب همم التركيز الشديد في عمليه الفصل
همم بشكل
اه اكثر
ايضا البسمه الرابعه والخمسين على وجهي
ومحيي والدي الطفلين وعلى جميع المتابعين
بالتاكيد شكرا لك من مستشفى الملك عبد
الله التخصصي الاطفال في الرياض مره مراسل
العربيه هاني صفيه تحياتي هاني
امر القضاء الاسبانيه مشاهدينا بوضع
امراتين في الحبس الاحتياطي بعدما اعدت
الى بلدهما من شمال شرق سوريا حيث كانتها
محتجزتين في مخيمات لعائله مقاتل داعش
قرار القضاء الاسبانيه ياتي بعد الاشتباه
في امراتين ارتكاب جنحه الانتماء الى
منظمه ارهابيه وذلك بحسب وثيقه قضائيه
ليله الاثنين الثلاثاء الى اسبانيا مع
ثلاثه عشرات طفلا تكفلت بهم خدمات الرعايه
الاجتماعيه في الوقت الذي لا تزال مذكره
الامير هاري سبير او قطعه الغيار تحققوا
مبيعات قياسيه انتقدها ردود فعل الصحافه
التي اعتبرت انه تفاخر بقتله 25 شخصا في
افغانستان عندما كان قائد لطائره
هيليكوبتر عسكريه وقال الامير انه بلا
شكاره انه بلا شك اخطر كذب قالتها الصحافه
هي انني بطريقه ما بعد الاشخاص الذين
قتلتهم في افغانستان اثناء خدمته العسكريه
مشيرا الى ان الصحافه اخرجت ما قاله عن
سياقه هذا وكان الصحوف بريطانيه وعسكريون
بريطانيون سابقون انتقدوا قراره بالاعلان
عن عبد الذين قتلهم معتبرين ان ذلك قد
يعرضه هو واخرين لخطر الانتقام
ولا مشاهدينا الى الاخبار الاقتصاد مع
فاطمه
اذا انا مشاهدينا دعونا نوصل حركه اسواق
المنطقه وايضا الحركه في الاسواق العالميه
في ظل الترقب الذي نشهده منذ يوم امس حول
ارقام في انتظار ارقام التضخم الولايات
المتحده ولكن ايضا على الجنيه المصري الذي
يزيد من التراجعات كنا راينا يوم امس 32
مستوى متدني تاريخي جديد اليوم نتحدث عن
عوده التراجعات على الجنيه المصري مقابل
الدولار 30 يتداول عندها بعد ما كان خفف
جوز كبير من الخسائر خلال الجلسه الماضيه
لكن البورصه المصريه نراها ترتد بعد
تراجعات المتواضعه التي تشاهدناها يوم امس
يضيف حوالي واحد فصل اثنين في المئه باقي
الصور الخليج نراها متباينه مؤشر السوق
الاسهم السعوديه يتجه الى الارتفاع في ظل
ربما الدعم من قطاع المصاري في البنك
الاهلي يعلن عن توزيعات نقديه لنصف الثاني
من السنه الماضيه وايضا يعلن عن زياده راس
المال ب 34% عن طريق توزيع السهم لكل
ثلاثه اسهم مملوكه دبي يرتفع ايضا بحدود
صف فصل اثنين في المئه مؤشر الكويتي يشهد
تصحيح قوي بعد سلسله من الارتفاعات
المتتاليه تاتي من القطاع الذي شهد
الارتفاعات الاقوى وهو القطاع المصرفي على
مستوى الاسهم التي نراقبها عن السلوشن
واستحوالها على كامل حصص سي سي همم بموجب
صفقه تقدر بحدود ال450 مليون ريال اماكن
دار المعدات ايضا من بين الاسهم التي
نشاهدها لاحظ الاهلي كيف بيرتفع اليوم ب
2.4% توزيعات نقديه بالستين هذا لا عن
النصف الثاني من السنه الماضيه وايضا رفع
الاسمال ب 34% عن طريق توزيع سهم مجاني
لكل ثلاث اسهم مملوكه امامك طبع وقعه
اتفاقيه معك لينكورينج ناشونا لمده هذه
الاتفاقيه حوالي 24 شهر بموجب هذه
الاتفاقيه سوف يتم تسليم همم مركزات
النحاس والزنك ليج اختار جلينكر هتوفر على
الخدمات الفنيه والتقنيه لشركه اماك دار
المعدات ايضا السهم يتفاعل ايجابا مع
سلسله مشروع جديد مع وزاره الصحه مقابل
166.6 مليون ريال انا اعود معكم دبنا
برامج الاسواق العربيه نحلل ابرز الاخبار
التي نراقبها اليوم باسواق المال
اهلا بكم
عبر الانترنت من خلال ثغره امنيه في انظمه
الشركه قبل ان تصليحه وتكشف عنه خلال
الصيف وكانت الشركه قالت ان بياناتي ما
يزيد عن خمسه ملايين حسابي تعرضت الاختراق
بسبب خلل اكتشفته اوائل العام الماضي قبل
ان تصلحه وتكشف عنه فيما اوضحت ان 600
مليون من بيانات المستخدمين الاخرى لا
يمكن ربطها بالحادثه التي تم الابلاغ عنها
سابقا او باي حادثه جديده
اعلنت الولايات المتحده واليابان في ختام
اجتماع وزاري عقد في واشنطن عزمهما على
تعزيز تحالفهم الدفاعي ليشمل التصدي لاي
هجوم عبر الفضاء وذلك في خطوه تاتي في خضم
تزايد التهديدات الصينيه والكوريه
الشماليه وارتفاع حده التوترات بشان وقال
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي خلال مؤتمر صحفي
مع نظيره الياباني ووزيره دفاع البلدين ان
الطرفين اتفقنا على ان الصين تشكل اكبر
تحدي الاستراتيجيين للبلدين
من البلدين هو هجوم ايضا على البلد الاخر
واعت ذلك قبل يومين من قمه الامريكيه
يابانيه بين رئيس الوزراء الياباني
تصعيد متواتر اذن بين الصين وتايوان يستمر
على شكل سباق بين الزيارات الدبلوماسيه
لتايبيه وردي بتدريبات العسكريه من قبل
بكين لتثير زياره المشرعين الالمان
والاتوانيين غضب الصين وتقوم الولايات
المتحده بمحاكاه ما يشبه الحرب المتوقعه
بين الطرفين
ترجمته الولايات المتحده بمحاكاه لحرب
محتمله تشنوها بكين على طيبه الخبراء
العسكريون في مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه
والدوليه قدموا 24 سيناريو مختلفا في مدن
زمني لي ثلاث سنوات
[موسيقى]
النتيجه كانت لصالح تايوان بشرط واحد وهو
التدخل الامريكي وحلفائه في المنطقه عدا
عن ذلك ستكون الجزيره بين فكي العملاق
الصيني في اقل من ثلاثه اشهر
ميكين الغاضبه متمسكه بمبدا الصيني
الواحده والتي تصر على سيادتها على جزيره
تايوان حتى وانقاد ذلك الى حرب بين
الجارتين
وكانت اخر التحركات السياسيه الدوليه
الداعمه لتايوان اضافه اخرى الى التصعيد
التراكمى بين بكين وتيبه في زياره
المشرعين المانيا
الى الجزيره اثارت حفيظه بكين معتبرين
تهديدات الصين مشابهه لحد كبير لتهديدات
روسيا باتجاه اوكرانيا
لدينا اهداف مشتركه واضحه تماما وهي تعزيز
الديمقراطيه عالميا ونساعد كل من حولنا
على ادراك القضيه بصوره لابسه فيها لا
يمكن ان يكون هناك اي تناقض اما ان تكون
مع المعتدي او مع الضحيه الرد الصيني كان
حاسما فالاداع لتبادل التصريحات بكين
سارعت باجراء منوره عسكريه تحمل من
التهديد ما يدفع الاطراف الى التمهيد
لفكره الحرب
عن ارسال الاشارات الخاطئه الى القوه
الانفصاليه لاستقلال تايوان وتوقف عن
اللعب بالنار
زيارات دبلوماسيه مستمره الى تايوان ترسم
وبوضوح الخط الغربيه الداعمه للجزيره في
وجه بكين
لتترجمها الصين بتهديدا للسيادتها ووحده
اراضيها وعمر العربيه
التي قد تصل الى 59 مليون وفى بسبب
الامراض المعديه وسوء الخدمات الصحيه
والعنايه
حول وفيات الاطفال حول العالم
المتحده من وفاه 59 مليون طفل وشاب قبل
الاسباب ارتبطت بالولاده المبكره الامراض
المعديه والملاريا والالتهابات الرئويه
الامم المتحده عزت الاسباب الى نقص
اللقاحات وسوء الخدمات وانتشار فايروس
كورونا
خمسه ملايين طفل توفوا في العام 2021 قبل
سنه الخامسه
مليونان و300 الف طفل منهم توافق قبل
اتمام بشهرهم الاول وانتشرت معدلات الخطر
في افريقيا خاصه والتي كانت اكبر ب 15 مره
من المعدلات في اوروبا وامريكا
ملخصه الامم المتحده الحل بتحسين الخدمه
الصحيه
من جديد انتقدت منظمه الصحه العالميه
الصين عن ما وصفته باحجامه عن تقديم
بيانات موثوقه حول موجه كوبي 19 التي
تضربها في الوقت الحالي وكاله المنظمه
انها لا تزال مقتنعه بان عدد الوفيات
المبلغ عنها في الصين يعد اقل بكثير من
الواقع في الوقت ذاته اشادت منظمه الصحه
العالميه بما وصفته بالشفافيه المطلقه
للولايات المتحده في مكافحتها في مكافحتها
للمتحول الفرعي اكس بي بي 1.5 من متحوله
احمد الكلباني شاب عماني جاء من بلاده الى
البصره بدراجات الناريه لحضور مباريات
بطوله خليجي
كما يقول رساله دعم خليجي شعبي للعراقيين
مقاطع تصل الى 1900 كيلو متر مره خلال هذه
الامارات والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
والكويت ثم العراق
امجد الكلباني شاب عماني في الثالثه
والعشرين من العمر استعان بدراجته الناريه
في رحلته الصعبه والمثيره في ان واحد معا
لحضور بطوله كاس الخليج بكره القدم في
نسختها الخامسه والعشرين التي تقام في
البصره الرحله بدات من مسقط من عمان لان
الامارات بيت هناك وكملت اليوم الثاني من
الامارات الى السعوديه الكويت على البصره
مسافه 1900 كيلو تقريبا يوم ونصف بالطريق
ودخلت على البصره الساعه 11:00 بالليل وما
شاء الله يعني
ما مشيت 50 متر اهل البصره يستقبلونه وكل
واحد يتعال وتفضل وتعالوا بيننا وما
مقصرين صراحه كرم مش طبيعي صراحه
يقول امجد ان الهدف من هذه الرحله ايصال
رساله دعم للتلاحم بين شعوب دول مجلس
التعاون مع اشقائهم في العراق
رساله حب ودعوه للخليجين انهم يقع البصره
دعما للعراق من البطوله وهي رساله المحبه
واحترام واهل البصره فاتحين بيوتهم فاتحين
قلوبهم الحكومه فاتحه الحدود ويخدمون
بعيونهم من قصر المعان
لم تعد هذه مجرد بطوله كرويه لكنها تحولت
الى محفل رياضي ثقافي اجتماعي يجمع شعوب
دول الخليج العربي
من قبل اهالي البصره الذين يعتبرونه واحدا
من نجومي بطوله كاس الخليج لكره القدم
بنسختها الخامسه والعشرين من البصره منتظر
رشيد هل العربيه
وفي الختام مشاهدينا نذكره بابراج
العناوين
موسكو تحاول السيطره واوكرانيا تتحدث عن
مقتل 100 جندي روسي في معارك المدينه
ناشطه الايرانيه تستغيث من داخل سجن افين
الايراني والعفو الدولي تدعو لوقف اعدام
المتظاهرين
محاكمه حوثيه لثلاثه نشطاء يمنيين على
يوتيوب بتهمه اذاعه اخبار كاذبه والتحريض
على الفوضى
واشنطن وتركيا
عبر الفضاء
الاخباريه مشاهدينا حسن المتابعه واكونوا
بعافيه
[موسيقى]